HA HA HA HA HA HA HA HA........ (You ok?)
I'm gonna pass out and give me some time
Whooo!
Whats up guys welcome back. I'm Grant Thompson the King of Random Lance Stewart here and today (cool)
And today we're down on Hollywood and Vine trying to experiment with Bunch O Balloons and helium
It's gonna be great. It's gonna be lit. No it already was lit. All right
So you guys pretty much know that you can fill up a hundred water balloons in 60 seconds.
Now what would happen if we actually got these water balloons and filled it all with helium instead of water?What would happen? What would happen?
HA HA HA HA HA HA HA...Batman
So the problem, I'm seeing is trying to connect the balloons to the helium
You can see it's obviously not meant to be
So wondering if we cut the ends of a balloon like snipped it here and snipped it there
maybe we can make some kind of a
almost like a shrink wrap idea and then use some electrical tape to connect it that may be enough to get the job done.
Ok so cool we got our little system
Jerry Rigged the question is is this going to blow it like a balloon first, or these going to blow up first? You gonna try?
Yeah lets try it out.
Alright.
Now, the way this helium tank works is all we have to do is push this little nozzle up, and it'll start releasing the gas.
So this is the moment of truth... is this little balloon connection going to blow up or the balloon's gonna blow up. let's find out...
Okay, here. We go. Sorry. I'm excited to see it. So you hold them up at this angle
3.. 2.. 1..
ooh!
That one definitely blew up. yeah, let's put some pressure on that okay, so you can see how..
When we add the helium here it actually blows up the connection, so we're gonna have to add
Add some more tape and maybe add some pressure on it with your hand that might help
Yeah
So there's a couple ways we can either hold it, with a hand here which might work or we could put more electrical or duck tape on it
to kind of form like a sleeve so I'm going to hold it first and see if we can just fist it
there we go, oh wow! there we go
(Laughing)
that almost blew out my eardrum
They're not going off on their own, but look at this we can actually
Look at that will they all go floating everywhere.. what if we just, What if we just get the whole bunch and push them
They're everywhere! you know that idea half works. Yeah, which I get these, why are these not filling up
There we go..
it's because all these tubes, oh yeah, you gotta get them all going at once I think
So if there's a way that we could like stop. How about you get all the straws and bend them down? These straws?Yeah
here we go..
Oh That's cool.
OOOH!!
There we go
It actually works that is awesome
Whoo instant Helium party that's kind of cool and the coolest thing is we got a couple more bunches
So we can we can add some color yeah lets do it. guys it worked
I wasn't really expecting that I was hoping it would but it was like an instant helium party just,
phsssh.. phoo!
there we go the ceiling is covered with little balloons, now this one just fell down
All right, so cool. We got a viable idea. Let's snip this one
Orange or green let's go with the green.. green it is. now I'm wondering like since we're just holding on to it anyway
I do you think we could just?
Make a try that actually hold it on yeah, okay. I'll tell you when
HA HA HA HA
i'm trying
whoo all right
how did it on the ceiling? did you see that it popped on the ceiling oh my God
What was crazy about that last bunch? Is there was you see that balloon closest to you?
Just got like three times as big as the other ones. and it was like hanging right by your face
and I could feel you flinching. Yeah. I was like. ahh its gonna pop right in my face again
WOOOOH! There they go those ones got really big look at this one up above your head. It looks like a pear wow
There they go for some reason that one worked out pretty well. That was like one of the best ones we've had
Okay, I can't reach it now too short yeah, so if we hold it out a little bit and then you hear that sound
Here we go
And away they go, you're all free go back to your home now. I have a party house. You know it's cool now
We've got this set up we can just literally pull this off
Perfect and put the next one on that works perfectly. I think we got it figured out
I got I got another bunch of balloons here. this one just fell I guess it's losing air
That's one thing. I was wondering is once the helium's in them is the helium Gonna escape
Yeah, I mean it seems to be that they're escaping in the only reason
I think they are because they're not actually tied there is just this little
Rubber band around it So it's definitely escaping a little bit
I feel like water doesn't escape from this, but air is definitely getting out of it
So what we're finding if we have this thing jammed up tight the helium is only going into certain straws
But if we can pull it away a little bit even it though and hold it in place
We can even out and if we add the gas slowly enough, we get a relatively even pressure
Yeah, we're going with our third batch here. This is the orange third tries a charm. here We go
All right, go ahead and push them off
You're free run away fly away
(laughing)
What i'm finding is very consistent here is only about half of the balloons blow up
And then we have to go and weed through and collect all these straws and pull em out of the way
Bend them over and then we can fill the rest them up, not sure exactly why that would be the case, but I mean
We have to cut the circulation off cause if not all the air is gonna escape through these
And it doesn't go through the other one grab them in the base there and let's just see what that does we go. Oh
There we go.. that looks cool
Like a flower that's right very pretty should i release yeah, add more take them off
Whoo they just went everywhere. I love how it's just like a fistful of balloons
They all go everywhere can we talk about how this balloons popped, but it's still stuck to the ceiling like that
Yeah, that green one right there. Go ahead and explain that to me. I have no idea how but it tends to have happened
you're right. It looks like it's sitting on the floor, but it's upside down. now your house is getting colorful
Look over here in the corner. They're all hiding out over here at a party house now start raving
So guys as you can see Bunch O Balloons and helium's was a sucess one stuck to my hair.
(Laughing) It's stuck to your forehead
Let it go up these things like you man things like you huge success guys Bunch O Baloons and helium was a a ton of fun
Big thanks to lance Stewart for letting us hang out with him today to crash his hat
We made a huge mess that means we're having a great time
I'll put a link down the description below so you can go check him out earlier today
We were letting him on fire
and you can go see that on his vlog. that was pretty crazy
And we deepend in my voice and almost sounds demonic just off of a balloon it sounds amazing
it's one of those transitional periods in life where your voice changes, but on a
tremendous scale
What were your impressions about the experiment today? It was insane. It was great
I mean, I definitely thought that this was probably gonna end up popping here
But we figured it out, and we closed that up and then they all went all over the place now
we have a party house the other thing we weren't sure about is if these little o-rings that actually hold the balloons closed for the
Most part they do although
It does seem that over time they loose and the balloons start dropping down from the ceiling as well
But it's a good short-term solution great party trick should definitely give it a try. Thanks for joining us for this experiment guys
We'll be looking for you in the next one. Talk to you then
(popping balloons)
ha ha. i can't reach it..
(Outro)